we've all heard of the bermuda triangle
right
where over the past 60 years about 50
ships and 20 planes have mysteriously
crashed or just vanished over the
atlantic
but have you ever heard of the nevada
triangle it's much smaller than the
bermuda triangle
and much more dangerous we're not
talking 20 planes not 200 planes in the
past 60 years the nevada triangle has
claimed
2 000 aircraft wait wait what that's
almost one plane a week
yep and it's not just the number of
crashes in the nevada triangle that's so
strange
it's the fact that nobody really talks
about it let's find out why
[Music]
a region of the sierra nevada mountains
between nevada and california
some 2 000 planes have been lost in the
past 60 years in this remotely populated
area of 25 000 square miles of mountain
desert many of the crash sites
are still unknown the triangle is
typically defined as spanning from las
vegas nevada in the southeast
to fresno california in the west and up
to reno nevada at the top
your question what's up put the map back
up
who owns the land in the nevada triangle
most of it belongs to the united states
government
yeah and what's that little spot right
there uh northwest of vegas
that's area 51. okay and when did planes
start disappearing well the first report
is 1938
right when did area 51 open they began
doing research in 1938.
i see huh but it's not just planes that
vanish
it's also people may i have my hat
please yep
there you go you know it's really
bizarre as these disappearances
aren't just casual civilian pilots that
kind of got lost
most of the missing planes were flown by
experienced pilots and disappeared under
mysterious circumstances with wreckage
never found
in many of those cases the pilots were
highly trained air force pilots flying
state-of-the-art military aircraft
the most famous crash involved famous
aviator steve fawcett
who vanished in 2007. his disappearance
ignited a massive search that led to the
discovery of eight more wrecks
a faucet was not some weekend warrior
this guy held world records for flying
solo aircraft
gliders even flew around the world in a
hot air balloon which sounds terrifying
this guy was also an expert in
cross-country skiing mountain climbing
he did ultra marathons
a triathlete so if there's one guy who
can survive anything
it was steve fawcett but on september
3rd fawcett flying a single engine plane
over nevada's great basin desert took
off and
never returned after a major search
effort that lasted over a month
he was declared dead then the following
year fawcett's id cards were found by a
hiker
a few days later the crash site was
located about 65 miles from where faucet
took off
two bones were also found about a half
mile from the crash site and the bones
were later confirmed to be belonging to
steve fawcett
where were the rest of his bones well
we're not sure but most likely animals
we'll probably never know
one of the first planes lost in the
triangle was a b-24 bomber that crashed
in 1943
the bomber with a full crew was on a
routine night training mission taking
off from hammerfield and fresno
and was supposed to fly from california
to tucson the one
gone never made it an extensive search
began the very next day when nine b-24s
were sent out to find the missing plane
but rather than finding it another
bomber went missing
it just vanished then in 1955 when
huntington lake reservoir was drained
for repairs to the dam
there it was the investigation into the
second bomber stated that the plane had
experienced high wind turbulence and
began to lose hydraulic pressure when
the captain saw what looked like a
snow-covered clearing he told his crew
to bail but only two jumped but the two
soldiers who parachuted and survived
made statements that the lake wasn't
frozen when the plane was finally found
it was resting 190 feet below the water
with its five crew members
still at their stations in the meantime
clinton hester the father of the
co-pilot of the first missing bomber
began a private search for his son that
would last the next 14
years when he died in 1959 he still
hadn't found any evidence of his son or
the plane
a year later geological researchers
working on a remote part of the desert
found airplane records in an unnamed
lake army investigators confirmed the
wreckage to be that of the first
missing bomber piloted by second
lieutenant willis turvey and co-piloted
by second lieutenant robert
m hester the lake is now known as hester
lake another crazy story happened in
on may 9th air force lieutenant david
steves was piloting a t-33 training jet
taking off from hamilton air force base
near san francisco
on a flight to arizona the plane
disappeared after a thorough search
without success the air force declared
the 23 year old pilot officially dead
but 54 days later he reappeared gaunt
and dressed in tattered clothing he had
made his way to a camp in the back
country of kings canyon national park
east of fresno
he said something in the plane exploded
so he ejected and dragging his parachute
to keep warm
and injured from his landing he crawled
over 20 miles in freezing temperatures
for 15 days without food or shelter
eventually he came upon an abandoned
cabin where he found a few cans of food
and fishing gear he said he survived by
fishing and hunting with his pistol
there were some who questioned his story
even speculating that he sold his plane
to the russians and steve's always
maintained that he was telling the truth
but he died only a few years later with
his story still in doubt
how did he die plane crash ew i saw that
coming and 20 years later
boy scouts on a hike found the canopy of
his jet so steve's was telling the truth
but the rest of his plane
still hasn't been found on october 4th
five military aircraft went down in one
day
one of the pilots was lieutenant leonard
c lyden who parachuted
to safety after the squadron got lost
over the mountains he said his p-40 fell
within a mile of where he landed in
king's canyon national park
they find his plane nope another famous
case was charles ogle a wealthy real
estate developer who lifted off from
oakland california in august 1964 but
vanished on his way to las vegas now he
was a marine corps trained pilot
but he was never seen or heard from
again and his blame
no sign of it this is getting weird oh
it gets weirder
ready to bring it in yes please you're
terrible at this
tower says the 350 requesting touch and
go that's the 350 tower roger report
over freeway for approach
says the 350 tower over
on july 11 1986 major ross mulhere flew
an f-117
into a mountain near bakersfield
california and the cause of the crash
has never been officially revealed
what do you mean officially well
congressional sources have said he was
flying an experimental aircraft designed
with special materials and structural
features
are these structural features disk
shaped we don't know
still classified no design is plain
lockheed martin
yeah a double hat me please
there you go now the stories go on and
on so what is it that's causing
aircraft to go missing within the nevada
triangle now some claim the area's
climate creates a special type of
atmospheric condition
that can actually rip aircraft from the
sky now in steve fawcett's case
some believe conditions created a 650
kph downdraft at the most his aircraft
could climb at 500 kph
so that speed difference meant he had no
chance of surviving if that's what
happened
if that's what happened the ntsb didn't
find any mechanical issues with the
plane so what was it
and why have so many other aircraft
disappeared in the same area well
conspiracy theorists
have claimed the reason so many flights
have disappeared has something to do
with area 51 where the air force is
known to test secret prototype aircraft
yep but most experts think the
disappearances
are due to the geography and the
atmospheric conditions the sierra nevada
mountains run perpendicular to the jet
stream which creates
volatile unpredictable winds and
downdrafts this weather phenomenon is
sometimes called the mountain wave
where planes are seemingly ripped from
the air and crashed to the ground
nope as for why so many of the crash
sites are never located
that's probably because of the complex
rugged terrain and the heavy vegetation
nope during the search for faucet eight
other crash sites were found so
chances are they're all out there hidden
within the peaks and valleys of the
sierra nevada mountains
nope or could it be something else
yep where the heck are we what is this
place
i have no idea
[Music]
oh i got a bad feeling about this
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files
if you had fun or learned anything today
do us a favor and give us a thumbs up
it really helps out the channel more
than you know thanks to detective lucky
in tampa florida for today's subject
idea
and if there's something you'd like
covered let us know in the comments
until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
you